molto probabilmente
se avessi scritto quello che sto per
dirvi qui oggi era avessi pubblicato in
un giornale qualsiasi nessuno lo avrebbe
letto o perlomeno pochi allora parto
raccontandovi un episodio è successo
pochissimi giorni fa c'è un giornale che
si ama express a washington che ha
chiuso per sempre i battenti dopo 16
anni di giornalismo e l'ha fatto
annunciando la sua chiusura nel suo
ultimo numero sbattendo sulla prima
pagina un messaggio che ha destato
scalpore un po ovunque e dice speriamo
che ti god alto schifoso telefonino l'ha
mandato a tutti tutti i cittadini di
washington che hanno preso quel giorno
la metropolitana
un po come contrasto tra tecnologia e il
giornalismo e allora mi sono domandata
ma possibile che c'è questo scontro tra
ieri e domani è quella classica frase un
po che genera il dibattito pubblico
ovunque con chiunque ma belli vecchi
tempi quelli della carta stampata niente
sarà meglio di un libro ma cos'è questa
cosa qui oppure il ragazzino super smart
che ti dice no ma il futuro questo con
la roma lieve che è datata però mi son
detta molto spesso noi pensiamo al
giornale come qualcosa di sacro qualcosa
di bello intellettuale quando in realtà
è un prodotto commerciale a tutti gli
effetti come un paio di scarpe o
qualsiasi altro prodotto commerciale ha
bisogno di investitori qualcuno che ci
metta dei soldi qualcuno che lo faccia
lo scriva e poi ovviamente qualcuno che
lo compri se manca qualcosa in questo
meccanismo
effettivamente non va e allora mi son
messa a capire ma che cosa non va in
questo meccanismo oggi perché ieri
funzionava e oggi no allora oggi
cerchiamo un pochino di dare una
spiegazione un po così di questo
fenomeno
io ho 24 anni e diciamo sono nata
nativa digitale non ho vissuto quel quel
momento un po storico dove giornalisti e
giornali erano considerati un po delle
divinità erano venerati amati da loro
passava tutta la comunicazione tutta non
c'era facebook instagram c'era niente e
quindi se un giornale scriveva male di
qualcuno
quella era la verità tu eri finito se
c'era un imprenditore il giornale
parlava male della sua azienda
anche lì è finito cioè non avevi lo
spazio post facebook in cui potevi
ribattergli è la tua vera cioè fine e
quindi è cambiato completamente tutto
nel tempo poi dopo questi giornali sono
diventati molto potenti si sono messi
addirittura i grossi gruppi
poi dopo quotati in borsa tuttora e dove
ricevono dei profitti incredibili
peccato che però nel tempo prima
dell'era internet questi profitti
finivano meno male nelle tasche degli
azionisti si dividevano gli utili e il
giornale rimaneva quello che era non
c'era un innovazione nei contenuti o in
un prodotto commerciale nuovo ed è in
questo contesto che è arrivato internet
e ha rotto tutto ha cambiato quella è
stata la rivoluzione soprattutto per il
mondo dell'editoria ovviamente internet
ha cambiato tutto ma l'editoria è stata
veramente massacrata e grandi giornali
erano ovviamente impreparati si son
trovati questi debiti enormi giornali
elefantiaci con migliaia di giornalisti
che mantenere non sapevano più come fare
la gente non comprava più niente crollo
verticale e questo è stato il disastro
dall'altra parte invece c'erano questi
blog che non costavano niente nascevano
così ogni giorno migliaia di blog
esplodevano i social networks quelli che
usiamo noi tutti i giorni e con loro
anche quest'ansia compulsiva ossessiva
dei click che fa più click click
cioè per noi è una parola un po così
lontana ma in realtà ha un valore
commerciale e dunque anche i giornalisti
sono dovuti
un attimo adeguare questa logica dei
click che aveva più click aveva più
soldi però non tutti sono riusciti a
cavalcare quest'onda ea portare click
sui loro siti
partendo diciamo dal presupposto che la
notizia shock sensazionale avrebbe
portato più click
però così non è successo la presenza sui
social dei giornali non è stata
convertita non è riuscita a portare i
loro lettori sul portale web e quindi la
competizione è esplosa e se ci pensate
effettivamente come può un lunghissimo
articolo quello serio pomposo su
politica internazionale o sul terrorismo
mondiale sulla crisi e il medio oriente
poter competere con un video magari su
youtube di un augurio che scoppia grazie
alla pressione di 500 elastici che fa 8
milioni di click nel mondo vi giuro
esiste se lo andate a cercare cede
ancora un caso incredibile di 8 milioni
di click di questi che fanno scoppiare
un augurio
io onestamente choc e non reggono quindi
la concorrenza non riescono a essere
rapidi con questo tipo nuovo
completamente di pensare cioè una cosa
del genere sarebbe stata impensabile
fino a pochissimi anni fa e dunque
questo ha creato un circolo vizioso
perché se un articolo non viene letto il
giorno dopo si riducono gli investimenti
se si riducono investimenti e chiaro che
uscirà un articolo molto mediocre e
quindi la notizia di per sé diventa
mediocre chi la legge è una persona
mediocre perché quando gli editori
digitali devono scegliere dove piazzare
la loro pubblicità perché dovrebbero
andare dal giornale che non fa niente e
lasciare il video dell'anguria che fa 8
milioni click
c'è la corsa delle alle imprese cioè le
volte in cui una pagina viene vista una
lunga e dettagliatissima inchiesta del
new york times con i migliori reporter
su questo mondo diventa identica ad un
post di chiara ferragni che mangia un
gelato
è identico perchè sul piano commerciale
valgono uguale a livello di impressions
e non di meno
new york times lo leggono due gatti
intellettuali entra chiara ferrania un
seguito importantissimo chiaro noi
diciamo che tempi però il commercio è
questo e quindi come cosa si può fare
diventa così impossibile creare dei
contenuti veramente di valore come
possiamo fare uscire questa questa
spirale nel bene o nel male facebook e
ricordo possiede anche uno zapper
instagram quindi quando diciamo facebook
in realtà capire che tutta questa cosa
qui racchiude il nostro mondo e internet
cioè dentro questo facebook abbiamo
tutto la nostra vita le foto i nostri
messaggi le dirette
abbiamo le foto del nostro idolo le foto
del nostro brand che seguiamo
assiduamente abbiamo tutto non ci serve
nient'altro e quindi anche un po la
logica in realtà di mark zuckerberg che
ha avuto la furbata di capire questa
cosa e di avere un piano strutturato non
sono mie dietrologie o complottismi ma
quello di far rimanere a tutti noi
dentro questi suoi social networks in
modo tale che non ci serve a nient'altro
c'era per esempio mia sorella piccolina
ha dovuto spiegarle perché che google
serve anche per altro non solo per
youtube
le ho dovuto spiegare come si fa una
ricerca perché lei usa solamente
instagram youtube facebook whatsapp fine
si trova in panico se deve trovare altro
dovuto spiegarlo è il modello devo dire
sta funzionando facebook ovviamente
incredibile azienda ricavi miliardari
funziona alla grande e ovviamente i
giornali si guardano con per dire che
facciamo noi sono rimasti ingabbiati e
devono rincorrere questi recinti dove
sono stati chiusi i loro lettori e
quindi rincorrere i lettori dentro a
queste piattaforme andando dentro a
questi social networks
ma andare dentro a queste logiche
significa anche un altro rischio e cioè
le regole non so le tue sono del social
network
se domani facebook cambia l'algoritmo fa
abbastanza
su facebook whatsapp instagram cambiano
le logiche vuol dire che cambia la
struttura della tua del tuo giornale
del tuo articolo potrebbe anche non
essere più letto e quindi tu devi
ricambiare tutta la programmazione non è
non hai più gestione niente non nello
spazio nelle regole e neanche contenuti
perché potrebbe decidere facebook che la
parola terrorismo non la vuole più far
vedere quindi decide loro cosa vogliono
farci vedere
certo sono un'azienda privata però hanno
miliardi di utenti
e allora cosa facciamo questi colossi
diciamo che hanno qualcosa che i
giornali non hanno più cioè hanno un
pubblico che li segue assiduamente
costantemente la fedeltà e la crescita
costante e pubblicitari non cercano
altro vogliono questo quindi è ovvio che
il giornalismo quello tradizionale di
una volta è completamente morto chiunque
dica no mari ritornerà no cioè
scordatevelo non esiste più
attualmente i giornali stanno
promuovendo un po in modo confusionario
scappano di qua e di là impazziti per
provare diversi ricette per vedere cosa
funziona cosa no c'è buzzfeed per
esempio che non so se conoscete e una
testata statunitense che funziona molto
online che ha deciso di fare una cosa
affiancare dei contenuti molto frivoli a
quelli più di peso
sostanzialmente dando tanti clicca
quelli frivoli per cercare di coprire i
costi quelli più pesanti e quindi potete
trovare dai gattini fino al super super
inchiesta sulle presidenziali in america
e riesce in qualche modo compensare
oppure c'è il guardian che ha pensato a
un guardian è uno dei più grandi
giornali al mondo di spessore quelli dei
nomi altisonanti che ha pensato di fare
una cosa io lascio l'informazione
gratuita perché eticamente
l'informazione è un bene prezioso quindi
lasciamo l'informazione gratuita ma
lanciamo una sorta di sottoscrizioni di
benefattori volontari che abbiano voglia
di aiutarci e ci sono diversi livelli
quelli dei 55 sterline al mese
15 oppure 60 ed andò dietro queste
sottoscrizioni dei
piccoli vantaggi come per esempio avere
un omaggio avere la firma del giornale
dal direttore oppure partecipare a quel
dibattito super esclusivo delle
presidenziali eccetera
così in questo modo riesce a mantenere
gratuita una piattaforma il times invece
ha fatto un'altra cosa si è sdoppiato ha
fatto due tipi di times uno molto
pesante uno molto leggero ma non come
buzzfeed un livello un po più alto però
è riuscito a mantenere due tipi di
giornali però se lo leggete non lo
mettete in dubbio cioè non è che dite ma
times ha perso credibilità
è un po quello che sto facendo io qui
sto parlando di cose serie
però se vado a cena con la mia amica
marianna stasera parleremo di smalti di
colori di smalti della nuova stagione
autunno inverno ma parlerò di questo
senza perdere credibilità cesso sempre
io
sempre il times però cambia il target e
cambia la comunicazione a seconda della
persona che ha davanti
perché se prima un giornale veniva
venduto solamente tra gli intellettuali
oggi l'informazione arriva a tutti
quindi devi capire che non puoi più
parlare solo a quel pubblico che avevi
prima ma si è allargato completamente
diventato mondiale globale anche quello
e quindi se cambio e target vuol dire
che se chiacchiero stasera con mia
sorella piccola di 13 anni e parlerò
delle hit del momento anche qui anche lì
non sarò poco credibile sono sempre io
e dunque comunicare se ci pensate
significa saper parlare a tutti di
qualsiasi cosa
il comunicatore non è la persona che
parla bene è la persona che arriva a
tutti il comunicatore quello bravo in
tutti i campi politico aziendale
commerciale qualsiasi deve saper parlare
a tutti quanti dal bambino di 10 anni
alla signora pina di 90 se un giornale
riesce a fare questo
allora sa fare bene il suo lavoro se non
lo riesce a fare vuol dire che non
riesce e quindi non sopravvive
semplicemente questo quindi la vera
domanda che in realtà il giornalismo
oggi deve fare non è come rincorrere il
sogno
facciale capire come fare i miei otto
milioni di click dell'anguria quindi
magari pensare di fare una cosa simile
perché non è quello il suo compito
il lavoro del giornalista e del giornale
e arrivare a tutti pubblici quindi
raccontare la signora pina in provincia
di varese le cose che le interessano
però riuscire ad attaccare anche mia
sorella di 13 anni che guarda solamente
antivir fino a passare all'ingegnere
della silicon valley super tech
questo deve fare il giornalista word
oggi quindi la vera sfida è riuscire a
comunicare in tutti gli ambienti e con
tutti quanti
grazie